[Music]
on this wednesday night here we go again
canada advises against international
travel as omicron cases climb i know we
are all tired of this pandemic how long
the measures will last and the effect on
your holiday plans and the economy
your risk of catching omicron and the
evolving rules on gatherings as ontario
ramps up third doses boosters are the
best way to prevent the worst
rising real estate prices how much more
a home could cost you next year and an
astronomical moment in the sun
we have finally arrived nasa sends a
spacecraft where no spacecraft has gone
before
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
ten days before christmas the federal
government has new advice for canadians
planning to travel outside the country
put the brakes on your plans now is not
the time to travel abroad
my message to canadians first and
foremost is
i understand this sucks
this is not what anyone
wanted
for our christmas holidays
not much in the last year and a half has
been what anybody wanted
the federal health minister acknowledged
today he knows the move may seem drastic
but says the omicron variant is
spreading faster than any other version
of the coronavirus and he's afraid
canadians who travel abroad could get
sick or stranded by travel bans and
flight cancellations in the weeks ahead
the impact of this new advice will be
enormous snarling family plans and
impacting airlines hotels and the
tourism industry abigail beeman has our
top story tonight
everything's kind of up in the air so we
can't really make solid plans
uncertainty for travelers this holiday
season as omicron takes hold met by a
new warning against non-essential travel
from the federal government i say very
clearly
now is not the time to travel the
advisory will be assessed after four
weeks we are afraid for what could
happen to them if they chose to travel
and once they have left canada there is
very little we can do to help them at
this point there's no change to who can
enter canada quarantine rules nor
testing those coming from the u.s are
not part of mandatory arrival tests
though the health minister signaled more
testing news to come
there's not a whole lot of solid
evidence to to support this
but it is a logical measure with the aim
to reduce
volume this long into the pandemic after
getting vaccinated people are worn down
and fed up there's a less patience for
another round of restrictions and more
pushback alberta's premier said several
of his counterparts are not on board
with more travel rules we have to
maintain some sensible balance here
the public will not i believe not
alberta not the rest of canada will not
accept
a permanent
long-term impairment
of basic act basic
aspects of a free life i think people
should continue with their travel plans
for christmas dr neil rau says you
should continue taking precautions for
anyone vulnerable in your group such as
a booster shot and masking derailing
people's plans this late in the game
just before they're planning to go away
at a traditional time of year when
people go away is cruel
it's unfair to people the advisory has
many with plans scrambling to make a
decision and wondering if travel
insurance is impacted make a call to
your insurer they've got toll-free
numbers to do it and ask the question
whether or not the coverage changes as a
result of it because many out there in
the market will continue to offer the
protection that you wanted global news
called a number of travel insurance
companies directly this afternoon all
experiencing high call volumes as the
industry scrambles to figure out next
steps abigail beeman global news ottawa
newfoundland and labrador is tightening
its own travel rules after detecting the
first case of omicron there officials
say anyone coming from university or
college must have a pcr test when they
enter all arriving travelers will be
given rapid tests unvaccinated travelers
must still quarantine the province says
the first case of omicron was a person
who traveled from elsewhere in the
country and they're now isolating just
17 days ago ontario confirmed its first
case of omicron and now it's already the
dominant variant in that province
ontario premier doug ford is
accelerating the rollout of boosters
we will go after this variant with
everything we have
i'm issuing a call to arms
hospitals
public health units
doctors
nurses
dentists paramedics everyone has a role
to play in the next phase of our
provincial coved response
starting monday every ontarian 18 and up
will be eligible for a third dose and
the interval between the second and
third doses is being shortened to three
months
and i need each of you to ask
what can you do to help
i need every business to ask
if they can host a clinic
or make their facilities available
and i need every person to ask if they
can volunteer at a local clinic and most
importantly i need you to book your
booster as soon as you're able to
capacity limits are being reinstated on
large indoor venues in ontario starting
saturday places like sports and concert
venues that can hold at least 1 000
people will be limited to 50 capacity
jamie morocco reports on the evolving
rules and what you need to know as we
head into the holidays congratulations
awesome
just when vaccines made it feel like we
were getting back to normal omicron
appears certain to set us back we just
canceled everything we are getting
together for christmas we're not having
any christmas eve party in ontario
omicron is now kovid's dominant strain
and experts are clear a double dose no
longer means you're not at risk
we have to give up
the sense that if you're with other
vaccinated people it's okay and go back
to assessing our risk based on just the
number of people you're seeing and how
close you are to them and whether you're
protected when you're close to them in
the setting you're meeting those people
in is it indoor or is it outdoor if it's
indoor how ventilated it is how many
people there are there you know how long
you're going to be there what sort of
activities you're going to do questions
that are all too familiar as assessing
our individual and collective risks
becomes our norm again our
recommendation is don't have mass
gatherings that means avoiding large
sporting events concerts even big
holiday parties dr allison mcgear also
suggests boosters for everyone over 18.
the way out of delta was getting your
second dose if you remember the whale of
omicron is getting you third failing to
do anything means more canadians without
question will get sick and while
overwhelmed icus aren't a guarantee
nationwide experts say omicron's
aggressive transmissibility means entire
hospital departments could have to
isolate imagine the fallout in a
critical care ward at a school or in
businesses
even one new person in your personal
bubble opens the door to covet some
holiday travelers have decided it's
worth it we were taking a risk we were
hoping it's not going to lock down these
are personal choices every canadian will
have to make but their impacts could be
felt by everyone jamie morocco global
news toronto
we know you have lots of questions about
omicron we're going to put them directly
to the experts if you have questions
you'd like answered before the holidays
please email them to your questions at
globalnews.ca
in manitoba public health officials are
urging people to reconsider their
holiday plans and rethink having large
gatherings manitoba has six confirmed
cases of the variant people are being
warned to prepare for exponential growth
new modeling shows the province could
have more than a thousand new cases per
day early in the new year
we need as many
uh manitobans to get that vaccine in the
next two weeks get that booster dose as
soon as you're eligible
it's our best protection against omicron
and any other variant
there was a similar warning in alberta
today the chief medical officer there
says the spread of omicron could lead to
the province's worst wave yet at the
same time premier jason kenney eased
some public health restrictions today
and allowed the public health emergency
declared in october to lapse people from
multiple households including the
unvaccinated are now allowed to gather
indoors in groups of up to ten heather
urix west reports
after its open for summer plan led to a
fourth wave disaster alberta is easing
restrictions just in time for the
holidays effective immediately indoor
private social gatherings will no longer
be limited to two households
in addition there will be no distinction
between vaccinated and unvaccinated
albertans private gatherings will still
be limited to 10 people though that only
includes adults the premier says he's
disappointed he isn't able to offer
albertans more we wish that we could
further relax these and other public
health measures now i was very much
hoping to do so before christmas but
regrettably uh what we are expecting in
terms of omicron spread requires that we
be cautious and prudent but this
infectious diseases physician says he
has concerns my initial impression would
be that the unvaccinated people in this
province pose a major risk to
our health care system
and i'm not in favor of
them gathering without restrictions over
at any point in time across the country
only manitoba and two regions in bc
northern health and the fraser east
region have rules preventing the
unvaccinated from attending private
gatherings over christmas nearly 85
percent of albertans over age 12 are now
fully vaccinated but there are still
pockets of the province where vaccine
coverage is low and with the province's
health system still under pressure from
the fourth wave alberta's top doctor
says everyone needs to be careful we
face a very real risk of experiencing a
significant fifth wave with this new
variant that could be worse than
previous waves in terms of overall
impact on our health system due to sheer
volume of cases a sobering message ahead
of yet another holiday under colvid19
heather urex west global news calgary
in the uk cases of omicron are now
doubling every two or three days and
it's now reporting the highest number of
infections since the pandemic began
britain recorded more than 78 000 new
daily infections today that is 10 000
more than its previous record set in
january when the uk was in lockdown in
london sixty percent of infections are
the omicron variant and the head of the
uk health security agency calls it the
most significant threat since covin
began while hospitalizations aren't
rising quickly yet the sheer number of
infections could change that and
overwhelm the health care system crystal
commansing reports
the wave of omicron continues to roll in
across the whole of our united kingdom
the warnings have turned into reality as
reported covet 19 infections hit a new
high i'm afraid this is going to be a
problem england's chief medical officer
says the new variant must be taken
seriously infections are now doubling in
fewer than two days
the growth is omicron
what we've got is two epidemics on top
of one another an existing
delta epidemic roughly flat and a
growing omicron very rapidly growing
omicron epidemic on top of it
those two epidemic streams causing
ongoing infections are also a concern in
denmark
it's just behind the uk and identifying
more than 4 500 cases of the omicron
strain
with infections rising attention turns
once again to the ability of health care
systems to cope france is struggling
with delta out in omicron and officials
warn 4 000 people could be in icu's by
christmas
this variant does not put into question
our strategy to fight the virus on the
contrary it reinforces it it makes our
prevention tools vaccinations in
particular more necessary and urgent
than ever omicron is spreading so
rapidly epidemiologists say that while
there's a lot of ongoing research what
is known already is troubling there is
evidence that is less severe
but the number of cases we have are so
many that that loss of severity would
have to be substantial in order for us
to not have real problems
exhausted health care workers are not
only being called on to care for those
falling ill but also to vaccinate others
as a means of protection
boosters especially in the uk
are the main line of defense crystal
gomanson global news
london
canadian blood services is taking
another step toward ending the ban on
blood donations from sexually active gay
men it made a submission to health
canada recommending the ban be lifted
and that men no longer be asked if
they've had sex with another man in the
last three months it wants screening to
focus instead on high-risk behavior of
all donors canadian blood services
claims the change would pose no safety
risk to the blood supply health canada
is expected to respond by the spring
many canadians feel like home prices
have already hit the roof how much
higher could they go that's coming up
there's not much relief in sight for
canadian home buyers struggling with
high prices new data from the canadian
real estate association shows the
average cost of a home in canada hit an
all-time high in november of nearly 721
thousand dollars that's up 19.6 percent
from a year ago that rise is adding to
growing uncertainty over what the market
could look like next year and gaviola
explains what could be in the
cards you have a very long life
predicting what's to come for the
housing market is extremely difficult it
defied expectations and came roaring
back with a vengeance during the
pandemic in fact 2021 will probably go
down in history as the busiest year on
record but royal lepage sees something
else in the cards for next year we had
an uncomfortably high level of price
appreciation
well about 20 percent in
many parts of the country
nationally home prices are forecast to
climb by 10 and a half percent to
average out at just under 860 000 next
year a single-family detached house is
expected to go up in value by 11
to 918 thousand dollars condo prices
forecast to rise eight percent to just
under six hundred thousand dollars
a continuing condo comeback in major
urban centers fueled by an increase in
newcomers and students from canada and
abroad with that comes renewed interest
from investors buying apartments to rent
out especially in the greater toronto
area the hottest markets toronto with an
11 percent bump vancouver forecast to
climb 10 and a half percent and halifax
to climb 10 percent driven by people
moving from ontario
and interest in other more affordable
options it's gratifying to see
calgary edmonton regina st john's
newfoundland
all starting to show price appreciation
royal lepage sees a winter that's busier
than usual omicron related restrictions
fueling more frenzy as employers slow or
pause plans to return to the office and
some homes become temporary schools
restaurants gyms and getaways think of
it as the storm before the calm
ultimately i do think it's interest
rates that that are going to have to be
raised to to bring this market to heal
and that's just what rate hikes are
intended to do
slow the parts of the economy that do
look a bit overheated observers agree by
this time next year with interest rates
and mortgage rates higher than they are
now the housing market will likely
reflect a very different phase of the
pandemic ann gaviola global news toronto
ahead suspicions of foreign interference
in the federal election campaign
the federal conservatives believe some
of their candidates were targeted by
foreign governments in the 2021 election
the party is not suggesting any
candidates lost because of it but do
suspect tough talk from the tories about
the chinese government may have led to
some kind of orchestrated campaign
against tory politicians our chief
political correspondent david aiken
explains
during the election campaign aaron
o'toole and his party took a tough line
on china i think canada's voice is
needed alongside the united states and
our five eyes allies to stand up to
communist china and their influence in a
negative way for human rights and global
trade and china's communist government
appears to have pushed back
the research project disinfo watch found
a coordinated communications campaign
run during the election by actors
controlled by the chinese government
that targeted mostly conservative
campaigns foreign interference
information operations influence
operations it's not a left or right
issue
it's an issue of our democracy that's
how we need to look at this
conservative incumbent kenny chu said he
was singled out by chinese proxies after
he introduced a private member's bill
that would have created a registry of
any canadian working for a foreign power
any foreign power many of the said
information is spread through for
example this social media platform
controlled and filtered by a communist
communist regime called wechat this
infowatch tracked a coordinated
disinformation campaign that falsely
claimed chew's bill would force all
chinese canadians to register and he
heard about that from his
chinese-canadian constituents they they
responded to me saying you know how
could you be
anti-chinese
people start calling me sellout traders
etc etc the conservative party has
brought their concerns about
interference in 13 ridings to the
attention of canada's national security
agencies but so far no action has been
taken still experts say what the
conservatives and some of their
candidates allege about chinese
interference is consistent with what
authorities have found in taiwan and
other western democracies donna all
right david aiken in ottawa thank you
next a nasa first and a giant leap for
solar science
it rises and sets every day and we
mostly take it for granted but the sun
is what makes it possible for life to
exist on earth yet we know very little
about it and for decades scientists
dreamed about ways to build a spacecraft
that could withstand the intense heat
and radiation of the sun
now as mike trolley reports they've
finally done it
for all the light and heat the sun
provides the earth the largest star in
the middle of our solar system remains
in many ways a mystery it's one of those
things that we're like we've got the sun
we see the sun every day we must know
everything about the sun already but
really we don't
and we're using cutting edge technology
right now to send something that close
to the sun
liftoff of the mighty delta iv heavy
rocket with nasa's parker solar probe in
2018 nasa launched the parker space
probe an ambitious spacecraft scientists
first dreamed of 60 years ago
actually that's not entirely accurate
astronomers have been studying the sun
for centuries but the only time they
could look closely at it was during
solar eclipses they could only dream of
a declaration this bold we have finally
arrived
humanity has touched the sun now the sun
doesn't have a solid surface it's a
giant ball of hot plasma that's held
together by its own gravity the wispy
lines of solar material that are
contained within the sun's magnetic
field are called the corona and that's
what the parker probe flew through you
can imagine the response from people
who've dedicated their lives to
capturing these images
is that the milky way passing uh yeah
absolutely
that's the mickey way yes amazing that
is extraordinary
thank you
of all the sun's wonders nasa is honing
in on two they want to know why the
corona is 300 times hotter than the
surface of the sun and they want to
better understand how solar winds work
because they can disrupt satellites and
fry electrical grids here on earth
and what we don't often think about is
you know the phone that we easily have
in our hands to check tick tock to watch
the news to check the weather app all of
this is really operated by satellites
the tragedy of a potential tick-tock
outage aside the sun is the only star we
know that supports life so perhaps we
should spend more time
appreciating it mike drew like global
news toronto
and that is global national for this
wednesday i'm donna friesen tonight's
your canada is the bc legislature in
victoria we'd love to see your canada
especially festive and joyful pictures
this time of year please email yours to
viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye
[Applause]
[Music]
you